this is jocko podcast number 263
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening and this
podcast is brought to you by
you
that's right this podcast
exists because of your support
and i've always dreaded having to say
the words this podcast is brought to you
by
whatever
but we don't say that and we're not
going to say that
we're here and we're able to do what we
do because you support us in a bunch of
different ways
and we own what we have here
and we don't rely on any companies to
sponsor what we're doing
which is nice i mean other than the
companies that we actually
own and we and the companies that we own
make the stuff that we actually use to
do the things that we like to do
and listen it is a harder road to take
it's a harder road to take you can go
that eat you can go you can go like just
get that money
and there's been times some people that
are on this podcast right now have sort
of
petitioned for that kind of thing
a little bit right well right
well and that's you know legitimately
because it's it's it's a much harder
move to try and build companies invest
in your companies and run the supply
chain and the personnel and deal with
all the finances and the taxes and the
thousands of things that you got to do
to make a buzz
business run and that's okay well guess
what it takes work takes hard work
it takes discipline because it's a grind
but at the end
of the day guess what that discipline
gives us freedom
gives us freedom freedom the freedom to
talk about whatever we want
the freedom to talk for five hours
without having to take a break to
mention some company we don't have to do
any of that
and we can make like i said we can make
the podcast as long as we want as short
as we want we can do whatever we want
we got the freedom to do that
we have the freedom to do that because
we also have freedom of speech
which with the
with the incredible foresight and
intention
is the first amendment of the
constitution the united states of
america
the first amendment is congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of
speech or of the press or the right of
the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances so there you go
the government shall make no law to
abridge freedom of speech doesn't get
any clearer than that
but it does get a little muddier than
that in in
modern times right they didn't have
podcasts back in the day
that i'm aware of so as smart as the
founding fathers were and as well as the
constitution has held up as a document
well there's been
there's interesting things going on
right now interesting things going on
right now and in some ways it's
troubling
because you see you can see
speech being controlled you can see
speech being censored you can see
meanings the way speech is being used
being manipulated
you can see words the meaning of words
being changed
and and we've seen this before
throughout history
and one of the best examples of this
it's a very clear example
and it's one i talked about with jordan
peterson
and when jordan was on you weren't there
the
second or third time that jordan came on
you weren't there
but we and it's actually happened with
every time
he's come on we've had some i've had
some plan about what we're gonna talk
about we don't talk about any of that we
talk about something completely
different so
so on that one we were going to talk
about the gulag
archipelago and by by solsha nitsan
and we did cover this one thing that i i
really wanted to talk about because i
think it's important
it's it's it's a it's an example of the
way
language drives thought and policy
and it's the one word it's the word is
kulak and
the what that word originally meant was
former sort of workers or peasants
that had become wealthy right so this
person's a kulak right they
they they were in the lower class and
they moved up
and then over time it became a little
bit more
pejorative meaning it had it it started
to take on a negative
connotation
so eventually it became social nitsan in
in the gulag archipelago he says quote
uh
a miser of uh akulak sort of became to
represent
a miserly dishonest rural trader who
grows rich
not through his own labor but through
someone else's
so so it's it's got a negative
connotation connotation
but he says about those kulaks
at the time that there wasn't that many
of them in fact he says that they could
be numbered on one's fingers so there's
a very small number of these kind of bad
people that had made money and kind of
made money off the backs of others
well as the as the revolution went on
the communist revolution went on
circa like 1915 1916 1917 the meaning of
the ward
started to encompass more more people
it started to and this is again this is
from this is from social nits and
it started to include people all those
who
in any way hired workers even if it was
only when they were temporarily short of
working hands in their own families
so you had something that used to just
mean someone that had kind of risen up
and and made it out of the lower class
into the middle class then it became
someone that
made it to the middle class but they did
it in a bad way
and now it's hey anybody that sort of
anybody that's hired another person is a
kulak
by the 1930s solzhenitsyn he says that
the word
was used to quote describe all
strong peasants in general peasants
strong in management
strong in work or even strong merely in
convictions so you can see this word
which used to just represent a very
small number of people
all of a sudden it starts to represent
more and more people if you have anyone
working for you
and and and eventually an official
decree
comes out from the government
it releases an official uh definition of
what a kulak is
and and by that definition a kulak was
any person who
used hired labor owned a
mill a creamery processing equipment
or a quote complex machine with a motor
systematically rented out agricultural
equipment or facilities
or was involved in trade money lending
commercial brokerage or
other sources of non-labor income
and this last definition made it so that
anyone
that sold surplus goods so if you had
extra stuff and you sold it
you were kulak
so now we're basically now talking if
you had a yard sale
right so now we're basically talking
about about everyone
and then the government set out to
destroy
the kulaks and thereby destroy the
strength of the peasantry
and the communists started a program
called decoulacization
we're going to get rid of them the the
the people that were identified as cool
actors again now there's a ton of them
they were ordered to give their farm
animals
their livestock to government
authorities so now so now we're taking
property
many of them and many of the cool acts
at this time are like okay well then i'm
gonna kill my livestock and
you know keep the meat and use the hides
and then when they tried to kill the
livestock instead of giving them up the
communists made a new law
which made it possible to prosecute
people for the malicious
slaughtering of livestock
this is like isn't it just you see these
steps going and it gets worse and worse
but that's still still left a little bit
too
a little bit you could still maybe move
through that you could still probably
get away with it
so then stalin decreed in order to oust
the kulaks
as a class the resistance of this class
much must be
smashed in open battle and it must be
deprived of the productive sources of
its existence
and development that is in turn towards
the policy of eliminating the cool acts
as a class
we're going to get rid of all of them
and by the way look at who we're talking
about we're talking about people that
we're talking about the people that had
stepped up and made things happen right
people that owned machinery people that
owned a mill
people that ran businesses that's who
they're talking about
well guess what when you do that when
you get rid of the people that own
farm equipment and farms and livestock
guess what happens
you run out of food you don't have
anyone making food anymore and this
leads to starvation
and and when you get starvation now you
get people that are hungry now you get
people now you get kind of a mob
rule thing going on and this is a very
horrible thing to think about
if you weren't starving
if you weren't starving or your family
wasn't starving
well how could you not be starving you
would be you would not be starving if
you had food
if you had food guess what you were
you're a kulak
that's what you are so so what does mob
rule look like
when it is approved by the government or
it's ignored by the government what does
it look like
there's a description an author named
robert conquest
he wrote a book called reflections of a
ravaged
century and this is a description from
that book
which is actually from a from a russian
journalist grossman
who said that the party activists
who helped the state political
directorate
the secret police also known as the gpu
with arrests and deportations
quote were all people who knew one
another well
and knew their victims but in carrying
out this tasked
task they became dazed stupefied
they would threaten people with guns as
if they were under a spell
calling small children kulak bastards
screaming bloodsuckers they had sold
themselves on the idea
that so-called kulaks were pariahs
untouchables vermin they would not sit
down at a parasite's table
the kulak child was loathsome the young
culak girl
was lower than a laos
mob scenario the book goes on to quote
a guy named lev koppelev a party
activist
so this guy was in the in the communist
game who eventually became a dissident
and he said it was extreme is
excruciating to see
and hear all of this and even worse
to take part in it and i persuaded
myself
explained to myself i mustn't give in to
debilitating pity
this is what he's telling himself look i
can't have any pity we
were realizing historical necessity
we were performing our revolutionary
duty
we were obtaining grain for the
socialist
fatherland for the five-year plan
so stalin ends up ordering the culox to
be
liquidated as a class which in turn
causes the soviet famine in 1932-1933
that results in at least three million
dead
socialists and said six million 1.8
million
were sent to labor colonies
only 1.3 million ever actually made it
to the labor colonies another half a
million of them
just disappeared gone look we don't even
know what happened but obviously
didn't turn out good for them
and then you have the rest of the
nightmare of
of the soviet disaster
and and you can pull that
thread and you get to this
language you get to language an attack
on language
on what you say on what people say or
what people don't say or what people are
allowed to say
or what people are forced to say
because our our words
they make our thoughts we think in words
and and and we have to keep our words
free
to keep our minds free and i thought
that we
learned this and if it didn't
if it wasn't obvious enough obvious
enough from watching what happened in
the soviet union
then when you read 1984 by george orwell
you were by george orwell you said oh
okay yeah okay yeah
got it didn't he spell it out for us
if you've ever read that book and at
least when i went through high school
you had to read that book
and at some point at some point i'm sure
i will cover the whole book on the
podcast
but without even talking about the plot
just talking about the world that he
paints
in this in this book the book is you
know
it was written in the whatever 1947 i
think and
but it's about 1984 and you've got this
omnipresent government you've got
surveillance everywhere everyone's heard
the big brother
do you remember reading 1984 no
no so it's it's it's a futuristic time
it's everything is controlled by the
government you've heard big brothers
watching you right yes sir that's where
it comes from there's a show called big
brother
oh okay is it about is it about a
dystopian future
no sir it is what's it about it's a
reality show that everyone lives in this
house like
a house but here's the thing though
dystopian
it's not dystopian well i guess is there
thought control
no but there's cameras in every single
room why don't they let me run a reality
tv program
i think it's pretty clear
but yeah so they they go around in the
house and there's cameras like mounted
cameras in all the rooms like
surveillance cameras essentially
and you can like tune in on off times
and stuff and just watch them
like you could do that like you could go
on a website and just watch the people
in the house yeah like they i think they
used to play it on like show
time where it's like big brother live
and you can just tune in and watch and
watch them do nothing like do
normal everyday stuff but here's the
thing there's i think there's now that's
totally common right because through the
internet you can just do that there's
people doing that right now
screening and screaming or streaming
their whatever they're doing their
homework
yes i saw something some thing about
i think it was a japanese dude who would
like do his homework
and he was getting he would have
millions of people watching him
he was super organized i'll give it up
for him but yeah if i remember correctly
could you see the content of this yeah
he was that's different it was like
there was multiple camera views you know
you could kind of see what he was
reading you could see what he was
working on yeah
and that's what he did he did his
homework or something like that okay so
that makes sense
if it was just a picture of him doing
his homework you couldn't see the
homework that's different that's weird
but
if you can see what homework he's doing
oh yeah that's good why is that not i
don't know why are you more inch i'm not
interested in his homework at all
i mean pretty much i'm not into video
games either but bro you can
watch people live streaming their screen
in a little corner of them
their face playing just playing video
games or whatever and this is like
multi million there's there's hundreds
of people that watch those
hundreds of millions per minute watching
that stuff
but uh the it's different because big
brother is like them doing normal stuff
all day all night that's a big big
brother like but
they have a voice in there too can you
give directions
it it says hey you're breaking this rule
or who makes the rules
uh the show or whatever are the rules
are the rules tyrannical in any way
i no it's a game show at the end of the
day it's like it lasts like
a few months or whatever i don't know
how long and they you know they have
little challenges defeat the opponents
in challenges so you can fight them
in yeah and then you have a vote and
it's like you know it's a thing
you know all right well that that term
big brother comes from 1984.
there's surveillance watching you all
the time
there's perpetual war going on there's
historical
negation which which is when you
falsify history or you distort history
and there's
a bunch of just really i was gonna say
cool quotes but they're not cool they're
actually horrible quotes but they're
they're they really capture what the
book is about
and there's one saying in the book who
controls the past controls the future
who controls the present controls the
past
all these sayings in there when you read
them you go
there's thought police who are tracking
people for committing
thought crimes there's people who commit
thought crimes
who and they or they don't tow the party
line
they don't they don't they don't toe the
party line
and if you don't toe the party line or
if you commit
thought crimes you become an
unknown person meaning you just
disappear and all evidence that you ever
existed is destroyed you are
gone you become an unperson
you get erased you get erased you get
cancelled
right sounds familiar right so you get
canceled
then they then this is crazy
in 1984 in the book there's something
called the pro
feed short for the proletariat
feed which is a steady
unending stream of mindless
entertainment which is produced to
distract and occupy the minds of the
masses
does that sound familiar at all yeah so
you can spend all this time
distracted and wasting and being just
mindlessly entertained
yeah it sounds like that video game
scenario it sounds like
it sounds like the thing you got in your
pocket
yeah which by the way gets even scarier
they have something called a telescreen
the telescreen
you watch it and it watches you
kind of like your phone which is
tracking where you are
identifying what you're watching like
it's what your phone is watching you
as much as you're watching it right we
this is factual
there's a word there's a world called a
word called
up sub which means you submit to the
higher authority
it's viewed in like a positive way and
and and then all these words
all these words are framed
on a on a new evolving language
which is called newspeak so we have a
new way of speaking
it's called newspeak the old way of
speaking is called old speak that's
english that's the english language
called old speak newspeak
is what we're talking now and they got a
bunch of
they got a bunch of these words and
we're going to get into the language of
it
but if you add plus as a prefix to any
word
it strengthens the word so good is good
excellent they get rid of the word
excellent they say plus good
because they're trying to limit the
vocabulary of people
and people have old think
if people have old think they have ideas
or they have memories that are
prior to the revolution so this is
right this is scary to think about
and and i know we don't normally talk
much about you know
current events really on this podcast
because there's enough because there's
enough of that
filling everyone's pro feed every single
day
without us chiming it i mean you you
you got pro feet coming at you 24 7 in
thousand different
angles so also
you know i'm not we don't spend a bunch
of time talking about wait what what
happened in the last
you know 12-hour news cycle
but you know the other day when we were
talking to cowboy
cowboy khan the vietnamese sock soldier
he gave me a little warning that i had
to pay some attention to you know and
he was saying you know you got to watch
out for communism
and i kind of you know i kind of brushed
it off and said well you know
we're a strong country um we
we are rooted we're rooted in freedom or
something like that and
you know it's in our blood and we will
remain free and and he kind of just said
be careful
because he had seen it take over in
vietnam
and i mean you want to talk you look at
the history of the vietnamese people
you're not about rooted in freedom like
that
that country is legit
they they they do not get they do not
take easy to occupiers it's in their
blood
freedom and look what happened it
happened and it happens
slowly
and you can see in this like like in the
soviet union
one thing that happens is it
part of it starts with speech it starts
with banning words it starts with
changing the meaning of words
and that's what happens in in the book
and there's all kinds of quotes in this
book
and they're they're just eerie
they're eerie when you hear them
and you think about the context of
the world right now i plucked out some
of the
some of the quotes
if all others accepted the lie which the
party
imposed if all records told the same
tale
then the lie passed into history and
became the truth
how about this one we know that no one
ever sees his
power with the intention of
relinquishing it
here's one the ideal setup by the party
was something
huge terrible and glittering a world of
steel and
concrete of monstrous machines and
terrifying weapons
a nation of warriors and fanatics
marching forward in perfect unity all
thinking the same thoughts and shouting
the same slogans perpetually working
fighting triumphing triumphing
persecuting 300 million people
all with the same face
here's another interesting one how could
you make appeal to the future when not
a trace of you not even an anonymous
word scribbled on a piece of paper could
physically survive
another section every record has been
destroyed or falsified
every book rewritten every picture has
been repainted every statue in street
building
has been renamed every date has been
altered and the process is continuing
day by day and minute by minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party
is always right
another one never again will you be
capable of ordinary human feeling
everything will be dead inside you never
again will you be capable of love
or friendship or joy of living or
laughter or curiosity or
courage or integrity you will be hollow
we shall squeeze you empty and then we
shall fill you with ourselves
and
and there's this book is just filled
with these eerie
eerie statements but
in the end of the book the the main
character winston he finally breaks
like he's he's resistant through the
book and he's trying to maintain some
some level of humanity and individuality
in the end he breaks
and and it finishes up by saying but he
was all right
but it was all right everything was all
right
the struggle was finished he had won
the victory over himself
he loved big brother
very very depressing
it's very depressing when the human
spirit is broken and it's even more
depressing when the human spirit is
broken
on mass which is what this book portrays
and and george orwell does a great job
this whole
this whole this whole
explanation and this trick and this this
thing that he does with language
is very powerful and it's
calculated and it's deliberate which is
which is
which is the way it happens and like i
said one day
i'm sure i'll cover this whole book but
tonight i just i just wanted to cover
one part of the book
one part of the book that i want to dive
into
so so george orwell who wrote the book
and he's got a very interesting past i
mean
he had a he's a very interesting guy
and the reason i say that is because
he's not just some
academic that sat in a ivory tower
somewhere he had a lot of experience in
life
he had been a policeman in india he had
he had fought in the spanish revolution
he'd been shot in the neck
so i mean this guy is not this guy's not
just a you know
uh just some person that's read a bunch
of books and is an academic no he's he's
been out there in the world
but he he wrote so in this book at the
end of the book he's got this appendix
to the book
and the appendix at the end of the book
is about this language it's about this
language newspeak
and in a way
it it might be the most important
message in the book or at least
maybe it's not the most important mess
in the book but it's at least it's it's
at least it's the least
appreciated message in the book
and that and that's why i want to read
some excerpts from that because
this part of the book really starts to
make you
think makes me think anyways about where
we are about what we have to be careful
of
so the appendix is written this appendix
that i'm talking about that we're going
to jump into
it's written almost as like an academic
assessment of the
new speak language so sometime in the
future
beyond okay in the book sometime in the
future of this book
some academic type person is writing
about
like a historical review of
this language because
you can tell when reading it that the
totalian the totalitarian state that
this takes place in
didn't work right at some point failed
it failed to really maintain the control
and suppress the human spirit so that's
a positive sign right
even though they got winston some people
stood up against it
and they were able to fight it off and
now you get this person
this this person writing this sort of
historical documentation about this
language
and you can kind of see he kind of
indicates that that one of the reasons
maybe that the
that the totalitarian government wasn't
able to maintain
control was because they couldn't get
full control of the language
and it's very interesting very
interesting to go through so
here we go 1984 by george orwell
and we're jumping right we're skipping
the entire novel
partly because i think most people have
read it
i hope but i want to jump into the
to the this appendix
so here we go
newspeak was the official language of
oceana that's the that's the
totalitarian state
and had been devised to meet the
ideological needs of ingsoc
which ingsoc is an abbreviated term for
english socialism
in the year 1984 there was not
as yet anyone who used newspeak
as his sole means of communication
either in speech or writing
the leading articles so so so at the
point that this
book was written at the point at the
point when 1984
in 1984 in this world no one was fully
speaking
newspeak yet that's why you could read
it that's why you could read these words
they hadn't gotten the new language to
where they wanted it to be
the leading article in the times
were written in in it
but this was a tour de force that could
only be carried out by a specialist
so only like people that were really
fluent in newspeak could write the
headlines it was expected that newspeak
would have finally
superseded oldspeak or standard english
as we should call it
by the year 2050.
meanwhile it gained ground steadily all
party members tending to use newspeak
words and grammatical constructions more
and more in their speech every day
the version in use in 1984 and embodied
in the 9th and 10th editions of the
newspeak dictionary
was a provisional one and contained many
superfluous words
and archaic formation formations which
were due to be suppressed
later it is the it is in the final
perfected version as embodied in the
11th edition of the dictionary
that we are concerned here so so this is
talking about something that you don't
get to see in the book which is the
final kind of
version of newspeak what they wanted it
to be
the purpose of newspeak was not only to
provide a medium of expression for the
world
view and mental habits proper to the
devotees of ingsoc
but to make all other modes
of thought impossible
it was intended that newspeak had been
adopted once and for all
that old speak was would be forgotten
and a hetero thought that is a thought
diverging from the principles of ingsoc
should be literally unthinkable
at least so far as it is dependent on
words so there was gonna be you couldn't
you couldn't commit a thought crime
anymore because
you wouldn't have the capability of
expressing what it was
its vocabulary was so constructed as to
give exact and often
very subtle expression to every meaning
that a party member could probably wish
properly wish to express while excluding
all other meanings and also the
possibility
of arriving at them by indirect methods
so you can even use like multiple words
to figure out how to say something that
wasn't on board with the party this was
done
partly by the invention of new words but
chiefly
by eliminating undesirable words and by
stripping such words as remained of
unorthodox meanings
and so far as possible of all secondary
meanings whatsoever
to give a single example the word free
still existed in newspeak but it could
only be used in such statements as
this dog is free from lice or this field
is free from weeds it could not be used
in the old sense
of politically free or intellectually
free
since political and intellectual freedom
no
longer existed even as concepts
and were therefore of necessity nameless
couldn't even think of it you couldn't
even think of being free
the concept didn't exist anymore they
eliminated the word
quite apart from the suppression of
definitely heretical words reduction of
vocabulary was regarded as an
end in itself and no word that could be
dispensed with
was allowed to survive newspeak was
designed not to extend
but to diminish the range of thought
and this purpose was indirectly assisted
by cutting the choice of words down to a
minimum
scary right yeah it's interesting
newspeak was founded on the english
language as we now know it though many
newspeak sentences even when
not containing newly created words would
be barely intelligible to an english
speaker of our own day
newspeak words were divided into three
distinct classes known as the a
vocabulary
the v the b vocabulary and the c
vocabulary it will be simpler to discuss
each class separately but the
grammatical peculiarities of the
language can be dealt with
in the section devoted to the acad
vocabulary
since the rules held good for all three
categories so this is the
a vocabulary the a
vocabulary the a
vocabulary consisted of the words needed
for the business of everyday life
for such things as eating drinking
working putting on one's clothes going
up and down stairs
riding in vehicles gardening cooking and
the like it was composed almost entirely
of words that we already possess
words like hit run dog tree
sugar house field but in comparison with
present day english
vocabulary their number was extremely
small
while their meanings were far more
rigidly defined
all ambiguities and shades of meaning
had been purged out of them so far as it
could be achieved
a newspeak word of this class was simply
a staccato
sound expressing one clearly understood
concept
it would have been quite impossible to
use the a vocabulary
for literary purposes or for political
or philosophical discussions
it was intended only to express
simple propulsive thoughts
usually involving concrete objects or
physical actions
so the general populace can't even carry
on
a political debate or a philosophical
discussion because they don't just don't
even have the vocabulary for it they
just can't even have it
so we're just we're just shutting it
down
the grammar of newspeak
had two outstanding peculiarities the
first was
almost a complete interchangeable
interchangeability between
different parts of speech any word in
the language in principle that's applied
to
even very abstract words such as if or
when
could be used as a verb noun adjective
or adverb
between the verb and the noun form when
they were of the same root
there was never any variation this rule
of itself involving the destruction of
many archaic
forms the word thought for example did
not exist in newspeak
it its place was taken by think which
did the
duty for both noun and verb
no etymological principle was followed
here in some cases it was the original
noun
that was chosen for retention in other
cases it was the verb
even where a noun and verb of kindred
meaning were not
etymologically connected one or the
other of them was frequently
suppressed there was for example no
such word for cut its meaning
being sufficiently covered by the noun
verb knife
so can you knife me a piece of cake
adjectives were formed by adding the
suffix
full to the noun verb and adverbs by
saying by adding y's
thus for example speedful
meant rapid and speed-wise meant quickly
certain of our present-day adjectives
such as good strong big black soft
were retained but their total number was
very small
there was little need for them since
almost any
adjectival meaning could be arrived at
by adding
full to a noun verb none of these now
existing adverbs was retained
except very few already ending in wise
the wise termination was invariable the
word well for example
was replaced by good wise
in addition any word this applied in
principle to every word in the language
could be
negative by adding the affix
on or could be strengthened by the affix
plus or for still greater emphasis
double plus
so for example uncold
not cold not warm as opposed
as opposed to uncool there's no word for
cool
yeah i'm seeing in real life there's a
word called uncool
and the short uh version is uns
that's what it is it's called yeah but
it's not the temperature cool it's
you being cool or uncool and uns
ons is like just short for it yeah so if
i'm walking behind you i trip your foot
that's un's i'm pretty honest yeah and
yeah actually you know what it's
it's more used for stuff that's like
morons than that
it's like it's so it's a little bit more
of a severe phrase severe yes
yeah i think so in my experience that's
how it like if i
if i trip you and you fall and it's in
front of some people that's pretty
honest
you spill your beverage on your i was
gonna say sure but we're probably not
wearing a shirt since we're in hawaii no
very rarely
yeah if you do it on purpose it's unsure
or no shirt i think
but actually you know what now they
think it's essentially the same thing
yeah
except the plus part i guess if you
replace it with very because there's
like plus plus right yeah you say that's
very cool
no there's double plus double plus yes
double plus cold meant very cold
dang it's kind of efficient
wait so uncold meant warm plus cold
and double plus cold meant very cold and
superlatively cold yeah very very cold
it was also possible in present day
english
to modify the meaning of almost any word
by prepositional
affixes such as anti-post up down
by such methods it was found possible to
bring about an enormous
dimunition of vocabulary given for
instance the word good
yes sir there was no need for such a
word as bad
since the required meaning was equally
well
indeed better expressed by ungood
i don't know this seems like there could
be a t-shirt possible
and i don't say that very often but you
know it seems like we've talked about
good
a fair amount and we do have a t-shirt
that does say good
yeah might be kind of cool to have a
t-shirt that said un-good
maybe a picture of a hawaiian getting
tripped up on the beach that would be
very
good yes very uncool
all that was necessary in any case
where two words formatted a natural pair
of opposites was to decide which of them
to suppress
dark for example could be replaced by
unlight or light by undark according to
preference
if you get rid of one of those two words
yeah
wait according to preference yeah so
they would just pick either
we got light and dark we don't need both
those words
so we pick one of them and then put on
in front of it for the other one you
know what's
actually kind of scary if you let it be
scary it's like
this whole thing is scary it kind of
makes sense that's the scary part
well well yeah okay there's no way that
i came from
that side came from the fact that when i
was when i was an english major
the english language there's there's
things that are met that make no sense
whatsoever yeah
like if you were a if you have an
engineering mind right where you like
you know the rules is the rules and you
try and figure out what
how to do english you're gonna have a
real hard time with it man oh yeah and
that makes sense because
bro when i get you know when i first got
into whatever i got into it was uh
html oh we're talking computer languages
yeah
hyper text markup language to be exact
yeah um and if you go deeper into the
coding
thing you know it's that's straight up
like that is
engineering mind right where it's like
bro the computer's like hey tell me what
to do
i'll do it but you better tell me the
right thing if you
i don't know i don't know about tones
you tell me the words or the characters
or whatever
and i'll do it and you can tell them
like accidentally the wrong thing
they're gonna do that thing
that's exactly what a computer does so
you better be specific
and if you're not specific it simply
either won't happen or it'll do the
thing that you mistakenly
were specific about yeah that's a little
something that
we like to call operator error operator
meaning i messed up you know when they
when the gps's first came out
when they first came out i was pretty
i was my first reaction was like why do
i need to carry that thing that thing
weighs 25 pounds
and they're like yeah and then they say
well you know you'll know where you are
and i go i have a math encompass i know
exactly where i am
yeah you know i i've had the training
i'm doing a terrain
study i know where i'm at i have a map
in compass i know
i know where i'm at yeah i mean
it'd be like you know if do you need a
gps to get home
right now me no from here no sorry
that's how i felt if someone when they
started telling me i needed a gps in the
field i was kind of
the exact same way you feel i was like
why would i need this thing where's 25
pounds i have a map i have a compass i
know exactly where i am i don't need
anything else to help me but there are
some situations
you know when you're out in the open
ocean there's no there's nothing to get
a bearing off of
there's nothing there so when you're
over the horizon you can't shoot a
bearing
once you get closer to the shore you can
shoot a bearing you can figure out where
you are
in the open desert sometimes too there's
nothing a sheet of bearing off of
that you can see so sometimes you do
need that gps but the
early gps's they
they weren't that good well they they
took a long time to find themselves but
once they found themselves then all of a
sudden i realized well this thing is
freaking super accurate
and sometimes people would get lost
right you know and then they'd blame the
gps
right and i would say operator error
yeah that thing did not
is you don't have the one gps that took
and changed the coordinates of earth
right yeah that didn't happen and sure
enough i'd pull it out and be like oh
yeah you missed a digit here
or you added to you know you you fat
fingered the digit over here
and that's the problem oh yeah that that
oh man that's so
that's so true so like in html as well
right so it's it's essentially like and
you you talk about your
english major and you know how it's like
i took a class called
advanced grammar and syntax yeah yeah
so the reason that okay saying i'm not
i'm
i'm not an english major but i talk
english to other people
and here's this little factor in english
is the is is one of the main
differentiators
between like the engineering situation
and the me talking you situation
i can use like tones and all the stuff
my emotion and all this stuff or
whatever and i can say like literally
the wrong thing but i can say hey you
know what i
mean though and you could probably say
yes there is that little
soft wiggly room you know or if i'm yeah
or if i misspeak and say someone else's
name but you know i meant this other
guy's name in a story or something like
this
and i can be like oh you know what i
mean and you'd be like yeah i know what
you mean there's that does not exist in
in
your html language yeah you can be like
you know five five five six one five
five five six one five five five six one
five five six and then maybe like a two
you know and then five five
thing's like okay two that's on purpose
boom let's execute that that's what the
machine does
instead of like all right hey do you did
you mean five five six one on this two
here
and then you know like a person will
think that you know yeah
i have this thing one time it was a guy
trying to um
explain like about the piano about
what what what how you play the piano
good
basically and so he plays a song
and he basically hit the notes like a
machine you know what i'm saying like
ding ding ding ding and just hit it like
it was some
famous you know song on the piano i
don't know what it was but some kind of
like classical
piano song but he plays it like
a robot basically just every key gets
the same
pressure and whatever and then he plays
it like
a human yeah and it sounds really really
different
yeah so there's a lot that's going on
better you think
oh the human one was way better yeah so
yeah
it's like this too it's the same thing
with guitar like you can get people that
pluck the notes
and they can pluck them perfectly but
then you get
you know jimmy page and he's he's
bending them and
yeah hitting the wrong note and bringing
it back i mean yeah yeah it's it's a
human element there's a rawness to it
yeah there's a rawness to it that's
positive yeah it's like
obviously millions of examples but like
you have analog and digital like even if
you go film
right if you go film there's little
imperfections in there that make it kind
of a softer kind of feel
and then digital is kind of hard even
though digital is getting so advanced
where it's kind of incorporating that
kind of stuff in that
but cgi for example like if you look at
early cgi you're like bro that's so lame
because it's too
perfect it's too like computer it looks
like a video game almost right you
forgot like all the light bouncing off
of this thing that leaf over there
and all the lights spill from this color
of this guy's shirt and all the
imperfections all that stuff is all in
play in real life
and that's how like real life is you
know and then but you try to recreate it
in a computer especially one that's not
as
accurate as real life which is going to
take a while right it's going to feel
like a computer you know
so i was listening to
someone talking about
making music and
it had to do with jack white from the
white stripes and
and basically when you get a drummer
like nowadays what they do if they if
you and i are going to make a record
so here's what we do you down here's
what we do
we take the record we we record a snare
drum
crack and we record 30 cracks on the
snare drum
we take the perfect one that sounds
perfect that's the snare
and then we take the hi-hat
and we get the perfect we record 50 of
them 100 of them we get the perfect one
that sounds exactly the way we want it
and then we take that and then we take
all the different drums we find the
perfect sounds we're making a digital
joint
it's a recording of a real drum but it
is
it's the same one it's a perfect shot
snare shot and they take that
and then they lay down the beat and the
beat is one thousand
percent accurate because it's computer
right it's
it's absolutely a perfect right right
just right on
it's right on every single time and
that right there when you hear it and
that's when you hear like a pop 40
whatever like a pop 40
music that's what you're hearing you're
hearing a sure you can be like oh yeah a
person played that but it got played
they can also take the drum like of a
drummer and they can line up
his he was off by a half a millisecond
cool it's all perfect now they line it
all up they line it all up
so you're hearing this what you said
you're hearing this perfection
and there's a
there's a there's a fakeness to it
there's something that we don't like
when you hear like for the white stripes
because we're talking about the white
stripes
or jack white he's he's doing things
like you're like oh that was he he just
did something wild right there's a human
there yeah
and and that gives it this reality yeah
so there's a we want to have that you
know i want to have that
did you think when i said what sounded
when you said what sounded better the
the mechanical piano playing sound or
the human what did you think i was going
to say the mechanical sounding one no
you're just checking me yeah that's one
way to put it yeah
exactly i wasn't checking you i was like
when you know how you want to expose the
example
it's kind of like that like where
because you weren't making a point
or were you i it didn't seem like you
were making a point that one was
necessarily better or worse you were
just identifying
what the difference that's what it
seemed like so i i yeah right
you're right i wasn't i wasn't purposely
making the point that one was better or
worse
i thought that would be self-evident and
if you ever heard a robot play a piano
you would know that it was kind of
self-evident that sounds wack
i don't know that i've ever heard when i
was a kid they had like these
um pianos that had these pieces of paper
these rolls of paper that
that would go through and it would it
was basically some kind of a
mechanical computer
that told it what notes to play and it
would think oh yeah yeah
the yeah self playing piano yeah huh
old school self playing piano yeah but i
would think that that would
still have this analog feel to it if it
was physical paper
it had a little bit it had more analog
than a computer because guess what
the the analog machine
is like not perfect it's still doing the
work yeah exactly right
it still has to like hit the note in
there yeah just to hit that little thing
has to hit the string
it's mechanical not digital right it's
analog i guess
is what we're saying yeah cgi has a big
one again back to that like you know how
they computer and still they don't have
this down at all
i don't know i mean it's they're getting
good i don't i don't think they're very
even close to it yet but um
you know they can recreate certain
things digitally in cgi like water and
machines and light and all this stuff
and some of it they have it straight up
they have it down
but if you come to when it comes to the
human face
the human face when it's and when it's
not animated it's good it's pretty solid
they can get skin
tones and reflections and transparency
all that stuff but when they start
talking there's so many complexities in
your face and
as a human being instinctually we
recognize them so
deeply yeah we just get we're not even
there we're not
so but aren't we improving our
technology so rapidly that we'll get
there a lot quicker than we got to this
point i think so
yeah i believe that is the case but as
of right now you can get the best
best best one when it's completely made
from
cj because now they get a real person's
face and they
match this and match that and even then
man it's really hard
um unless it's like a super simple
expression or
or a pause or something like that but
you get someone to talk a a cgi
face to talk no matter how good it is it
looks weird it looks
actually scary because it looks like oh
are you trying to be a person what about
the deep fakes
uh somebody just posted a deep fake of
me yeah so the defects are a little bit
different because it's kind of cool
oh yeah those are kind of scary too
though when you
when you think about it or whatever this
i mean for different reasons obviously
but um yeah the deep fakes they take
an actual face though it's not recreated
digitally they take your actual face
from a million or however many available
representations of your face it actually
exists
they take that and then they match it up
to another phase so
that's a different process but if you
get a basically essentially a sculptor
and a rigger it's rigging it means like
oh i'm going to control this eyebrow and
this
eyelid and all this stuff you rig
everything the best best guys
it's gonna look like a weird like a
weird monster and
there's a word for it the the fact that
it's weird
it's called the uncanny valley and it's
like so it's this valley between the
real deal
recognizing it as the real deal and then
a fake deal
so the smaller the uncanny valley the
more offsetting it is
so if it's like a straight up robot face
like remember the back
like short circuit remember that that
movie short circuit
number five anyway but i did watch et
the other day with
i don't even there's obviously no cgi in
there but man
i hadn't seen et since i was 10 or
whatever
whatever it came out i saw in the
theater and like i remembered like this
really
good movie you know like space aliens
have you watched it lately no i was
i was really kind of unknown
my mom stephen spielberg if you're out
there i like
i get it you were working with what you
had at the time
all good jaws is one of my favorite
movies ever so i appreciate that 100
percent
but you know when i saw et bro it was
kind of it was a it was
definitely not what you know why wait
what about it like that
well for one thing this quote special
effects
like e.t looks like a like a doll that
someone's moving around
it's crazy to watch maybe his planet
that's how they look
you see them saying don't come at me
but there isn't actually an argument
because they call that practical effects
versus
visual effects so like practical effects
is like um yeah like the physical thing
visual is like cgi right um
there's a big argument for practical
effects they should develop that i like
practical feelings yeah i think we all
do
but the the uncanny valley thing
like e.t even for example if it's so
obviously not a person
no one can it's not going to off-put
anybody everyone's gonna be like okay
cool it's a non-person
whatever it is robot alien whatever but
if it is a person
but it's not exactly exactly straight up
a real person
everyone's gonna be freaking weirded out
by that thing
so what's what's to bring this back to
what we're talking about and believe it
or not this entire
uh rabbit hole we just went down to down
is
absolutely applicable what we're talking
about because what we're talking about
is
we're talking about removing the ability
for
human beings to express themselves
properly
we're removing that ability when we
remove words from the language
we're removing the ability for humans to
express themselves and therefore we are
removing
the ability to think
and that is a scary thing yeah
yeah it's like the the difference
between you know when you take a test
and there's all kinds of tests right so
there's like if you go down the spectrum
of tests there's like the
the essay question or the thesis really
the
straight up thesis there's probably more
comprehensive tests than that but
well thesis yeah then you got your essay
question
test then you got a multiple choice
and then true false no actually there's
a few before multiple choice because you
got your um
like hey what's this and you have to say
the answer okay fill in the def
fill in the daf fill in the blanks
sentence word whatever
and you got your multiple choice right
abc d e
all all the above none of the above
whatever then you got your
true false false yeah so now you got
just straight binary now
it's true false no room
for freaking nuance no nothing you seem
saying what test did you prefer the most
well depends depends what how old that
was
and what you know what the subject was
for sure if i didn't care
if i just wanted the [ __ ] eight
obviously the true false
really i always felt like i always felt
like i had a little bit of uh
better you know because maybe i wasn't
you know when
we're talking we're talking you know
teenage years
maybe i wasn't quite really doing much
studying
at that time so i could
maybe write a better essay and fill in
the blanks a little
bit about what you know maybe there's a
concept because i was good if i
understood a concept i could kind of run
with it
yeah whereas true false like what
happened on this date i'd be like
because i didn't
read i didn't study it you know yeah now
when i went to college i was like
bring it i was like what tasty what kind
of taste you want to give me yeah
but a lot of those so true and i'm sure
educators have a good grasp on why you
would ever
administer a true false question test
versus
you know any of the other ones and i
hope anyway because
man if you're doing like a like a
history true false
like that's way more dangerous because
of like how much nuance or in
perspective like
if you go okay so my daughter will ask
me questions and i'll always answer and
i told you this before
where i'll always answer with deep ends
like what's your what's your favorite
color freaking defense good one
bro my favorite color what wearing stuff
or
my car or bro it's different you know or
or not even necessarily it is different
let me say black can be
tiger striped camo
most actually my favorite color actually
is black and they know that but then
she'll always probe me be like what's
your favorite color what's your
favorite color and then so it makes you
think about it you know
so i'm like black but bro i'm not going
to wear like
black under in certain circumstances
certain blacks
so speaking of tests and speaking of
language because i'm over here just
trying to reel things back into
subjects which is you know cool opposing
forces
so check this out when you when you when
you went to college
and you took was there a possibility of
taking a class
where you wouldn't get graded by a
letter but you would either
get through the class or not get through
the class yeah
what was that called pass no pass okay
so when i would because as my my uh one
of my daughters in college
they're like offering now since
everything's online you can take every
class
she says i can t you know she said
they're telling us we could take every
class past no pass
oh that's like the option when i was a
kid you know what it's called
pass fail yeah that's that's what i mean
that's what it was in our studio it was
called pass fail yeah now it's called
pass
no pass no pass right right right right
right right right right right right
right fun yes unpassed
right because we remove the word fail
out of the vocabulary yeah i might might
mess with people's self-esteem man
yeah there's your fail right there
all right we're getting back to the book
the second distinguishing mark of
newspeak
grammar was its regularity subject to
few exceptions which were mentioned
below
all inflections followed the same rules
thus in all verbs the preterit
and past participle were the same and
ended
in ed the predative steel was steeled
the predator of think was thinked and so
on
throughout the language all such forms
such as swam gave brought
spoke taken being abolished so you like
this part because now it's all
more uniformed the rules are all plurals
were made by adding s's or ess as the
case might be
the the plurals of man ox life
were mans oxes life's
comparison of adjectives was invariably
made by adding er or est good
gooder goodest
irregular forms and more and the more
most formation being suppressed so they
got rid of they got rid of more and most
and just got
good good or goodist
the only classes of words which were
still allowed to inflict regularly were
the pro-man
pronouns the relatives the demonstrative
adjectives and the auxiliary verbs
all of these followed their ancient
usage except that whom had been scrapped
is unnecessary
and the shall should tenses have been
dropped all their use of being covered
by will and wood there were
also certain irregularities in word
formation arising out of the need for
rapid and easy speech
a word that was difficult to utter was
liable to be incorrectly heard
was held to be ipso facto a bad word
occasionally
therefore for the sake of of euphemism
euphony
extra letters were inserted into a word
or an archaic formation
was retained but this was but this
need made itself felt chiefly in
connection with the
b vocabulary why
so great and importance was attached to
ease of pronunciation will be made clear
later in this essay so
one of their main purposes was to make
these things
easy to say and not and clear yeah
we're trying to dumb everything down for
society yeah
yeah like you know how every once in a
while you see like one of these little
diagrams and they say like
i don't know if they actually i don't
think they say
this is proper but the whole diagram
implies that it's proper
so it's like very good and then they say
don't say very good
say excellent don't say whatever say
that you know they like they tell you
the actual
yeah word for like don't and it's
it in a weird way it almost seems like
it's the opposite of that you know
where if it's like hey yeah they're
trying to expand your vocabulary yes it
is
like when you're in when you write a a a
english paper in
ninth grade and you say
the chicken that i ate last night was
very very very dry
yeah yeah you get chocolate
you don't you come up with a better word
right don't just put another very on
that thing to give it another level of
yeah goodness yeah yeah that's what
that's
that's a beautiful thing that's the way
it should be right we should be
we should be people should be learning
more words our
vocabulary should be growing yeah you
know what's
interesting is that very interesting
very interesting
fascinating what is what's the next word
fascinating we'll go fascinating because
no interesting kind of seems ambiguous
like it's interesting in a good way or a
bad way
you know true fascinating is like i'm
it's like
wonderfully interesting okay is that
where is that
there it is no yeah maybe i don't know
certain levels
anyway um even in slang
we have that you know like even
i like think of an example strangely but
you know like how slangy like you'll
have it like oh yeah you're uh
okay these are all swear words so i
don't wanna do that example
but you can be like oh yeah he's cool or
he's
um whack dwack or he's
dope or he's what you know and there's
all these escalating levels
hierarchy of compliments yeah you know
so you could say oh yeah he's
cool or you can say he's very cool or
you can say he's like the be his niece i
don't know i just made that up or
whatever i didn't make it up just
thought of it but
you know how like there's different
slang words for different degrees of
certain so even slang has an escalating
uh hierarchy of words to explain things
yeah the expanded slang vocabulary
exists as well uh now we get into the b
vocabulary the b vocabulary consisted of
words which have been deliberately
constructed for political purposes
words that is to say which not only had
every case
in every case a political implication
but were intended to impose desirable
a desirable mental attitude on the
person using them without
a full understanding of the principles
of ingsoc it was difficult
to use these words correctly in some
cases they could be translated
into old speak or even in words taken
from a vocabulary but this
usually demanded a long paraphrase and
always involved
the loss of certain overtones the b
words were a sort of verbal shorthand
often packing whole ranges of ideas into
a few syllables
and at the same time more accurate and
forcible than ordinary language
the b words were in all cases compound
words they consisted of two or more
words
or portions of words welded together
in an easily pronounceable form
the resulting was always a noun verb and
inflected
according to the ordinary rules to take
a simple example the word
good think meaning very roughly
orthodoxy or if one choose to regard it
as a verb to think in an orthodox manner
this inflected as follows noun verb
good think the past tense and past
participle good thinked present
participle good thinking adjective good
thinkful
and adverb good think wise verbal noun
good thinker
the b words were not constructed on
any etymological plan
the words of which they were made up
could be parts of any speech could be
placed in any order and mutilated in any
way
which made them easy to pronounce while
indicating their derivat
their derivatives in the word crime
think
thought crime for instance the think
came
second whereas in think poll which was
the thought police
it came first and in the latter the word
police had lost its second syllable
because the great difficulties in making
it sound
good irregular formations were commoner
in the b vocabulary than the a
vocabulary for example
adjective forms of miniature me are
sorry mini true
mini packs mini love or respectively
the minis ministry of truth many
truthful many peaceful
many lovely simply because truthful
pactful and lovely
loveful were slightly awkward to
pronounce
he went deep on this some of the b
words had highly subt subtilized
meanings
subtlized meetings barely intelligible
to anyone who had not mastered the
language as a whole consider for example
the typical sentence from a times
leading article as old think
old thinkers unbelly feeling sock
the shortest rendering that could make
this of
that could make that one could make of
this an old speak would be those whose
ideas were formed before the revolution
cannot
have a full emotional understanding of
the principles of english
socialism so that whole sentence gets
translated into
old thinkers unbelief ing sock
ah
the greatest difficulty facing the
compilers of new speak of the newspeak
dictionary was not to invent new words
but having invented them
to make sure what they meant to make
sure that is to say
what ranges of words they cancelled
because of their existence
if you if you made up a new word it had
to get rid of a bunch of other words
yeah
we have already seen that in the case
the word free words which had once
borne a heterical a heretical a
heretical message
meaning were sometimes retained for the
sake of convenience
but only with the undesirable meanings
purged out of them
other words such as honor justice
morality internationalism democracy
science and religion
had simply ceased to exist
a few blanket words covered them and in
covering them
abolished them all words grouping
themselves around the concepts of
liberty
and equality for instance were contained
contained in the single word
crime think while all words grouping
themselves around the concepts of
objectivity and rationalism were
contained in the single world
word old think
man
that's really disturbing to think about
just the fact that you take you get rid
of the words
and now how do we even you know how do
you teach it to your kids
greater precision would have been
dangerous what was required in a party
member was an
outlook similar to that of the ancient
hebrew who knew
without knowing much else that all
nations other than his
own worshipped false gods he did not
need to know that these gods were called
baal osiris maluk and the like
probably the less he knew about them the
better for
his orthodoxy that's a very cool
explanation he knew jehovah
and the commanders of jo and the
commandments of jehovah he knew
therefore
that all gods with other names or other
attributes were false gods
in somewhat the same way the party
member knew what constituted right
conduct
and in exceedingly vague generalized
terms
he knew what kinds of departure from it
were possible
you only know the right and everything
else is just bad everything else is
false everything else is lie that's all
you need to know
no b word no word in the b vocabulary
was ideologically neutral
a great many name names were euphemisms
words such words for instance says joy
camp
which is a forced labor camp or mini pax
which is the ministry of war
which is the ministry of peace is what
it was short for but it really meant the
ministry of war
meant almost the exact opposite of what
they appeared to mean some words on the
other hand displayed a frank
and contemptuous understanding of the
real nature of oceanic society
an example was pro feed meaning the
rubbishy entertainment and spurious news
which the party
handed out to the masses other words
again were ambit
ambivalent having the connotation good
when applied to the party and bad when
applied to its enemies
good thinking bad thing but in addition
there were great numbers of words which
at first
sight appeared to be mere abbreviations
and which derived their ideological
color
not from their meaning but from their
structure
fast forward a little bit talk starts
talking about um in the ministry of
truth for example the records department
in which winston smith works
worked was called the wreck depp the
fictional department was called the fick
depp
the teleprograms department was called
the teledep and so on
this was not done solely with the object
of saving time
even in the early decades of the 20th
century telescoped words and phrases
had been one of characteristic features
of political language
and had been noticed that the tendency
to use abbreviations of this kind
was most marked in totalitarianism
countries and totalitarian organizations
examples were such words as nazi gestapo
common turn agi-prop
in the beginning the practice had been
adopted as
as it were instinctively but newspeak
but
but in newspeak it was used with a
conscious purpose
it was perceived that in thus
abbreviating
a name one narrowed the subtlety
altered and altered its meaning by
cutting out most of the associations
that would otherwise cling to it
that's very interesting the words
communist international for instance
call
up a composite picture of universal
human brotherhood
red flags barricades karl marx and the
paris commune the word common turn
on the other hand suggests merely a
tight-knit organization of well-defined
body of doctrine it refers to something
almost
as easily recognized and limited in
purpose as a channel table i wonder why
i use communism term instead of nazis
it seems like nazis is the like national
socialism
those two words have their own meanings
you know and
and you know you can attach a bunch of
things to nationalism and socialism
but you know when you put those words
together and show them into nazi
it doesn't get more obvious that we just
made something different and
and like he's saying it makes it a tight
group it removes
all the other things that can hang on to
these words
in the same way the associations called
up by a word like many true are fewer
and more controllable than those called
up by ministry of truth
this accounted for the habit not only
the habit of abbreviating whenever
possible but also
for the almost exaggerated care that was
taken to make every word
easily pronounceable
for the purposes of everyday life it was
no doubt necessary or sometimes
necessary
to reflect before speaking but a party
member a party member called upon to
make a political or ethical judgment
should be able to spray forth the
correct opinions as automatically as a
machine gun
spraying forth bullets his training
fitted him to do this
the language gave him an almost
foolproof instrument
and the texture of the words and their
harsh sound and certain willfulness
willing willful ugliness which was in
accord with the spirit of ingsoc
assisted the process further this that
that little section there's like remind
me of what you see today when
people just have their go-to terms that
they're that's that's what they're going
to throw
right they just have they're just going
to attack with the
the the
the damn attack words
you know like i'm coming at you right
uh you just you just hear it what are
the buzzwords that's what i was looking
for
one of the cliche yeah but they're
coming at you with a cliche uh like oh
that guy's a commie that guy's a nazi
you know they they they got they're just
gonna you know
you you're on the other side cool you're
a nazi oh right like
they they kind of throw it all kind of
into one
almost like yeah yeah here's here's my
argument you know you say
hey jocko um i think that uh
there should be voter id in america and
i say you're a nazi
right right you know like that's that's
kind of the same thing and then
basically then all my friends start
calling you a nazi as well right right
or racist
and then and then i say well you know
echo i think that we should have
uh you know some form of
welfare to help people out and you're
like you're a commie and all your
friends call me a community so that's
like
that's what i'm saying that's what that
reminds me of everybody
should be able to spray forth the
correct opinions as automatically as a
machine gun spraying forth bullets
correct opinion yep
scary
then you get into the c vocabulary and
when you get in the c vocabulary
there was indeed no word for science
any meaning that could possibly bear
being
already covered by the word ingsoc so
so everything is just it's just based on
ing sock
and science that's just being that's
what they say is correct
that's science so you don't need all
these other words
and and and see vocabulary was
supplementary to others
and consistent entirely of scientific
and technical terms
but like i said there's not too many of
them
um ideas
inimical to ingsoc which is like hostile
ingsoc could be
could only be entertained in a vague
wordless form
and could not only be named in very
broad terms
which lump together and condemned whole
groups
of heresies without defining them and
doing so
so it's kind of similar to what i just
said oh
you you want
you you're you're you're a conservative
you're a nazi oh you're a liberal you're
a kami
that's the same thing right your whole
group is just
nazis your whole group is just commies
that's where we're at
right
the concept of political equality no
longer existed
and this secondary meaning had
accordingly been purged out of the word
equal
in 1984 when oldspeak was still the
normal means of communication the danger
theoretically existed that in using
newspeak
words one might remember their original
meanings
in practice it was not difficult for any
person to be well grounded in double
think
to avoid doing this but within a lapse
within a couple generations even the
possibility of such a lapse would have
vanished
so they're going to get rid of the
language over time like my kid might
remember the other meaning of the word
free
but his kids are going to maybe maybe
maybe his kids but
by the time you get two generations
we're good no more freedom not even
not even a thought
getting to the end here when old spit
i'm fast forwarding through a bunch of
stuff
when old speak had been once and for all
superseded the last
link with the past would have been
severed
so if they could have gotten control the
language they would have made it
history had already been rewritten but
fragments of the literature of the past
survived here and there
imperfectly censored they didn't quite
get rid of all the language
and so long as one retained one's
knowledge of old speak it was possible
to read them
in the future such fragments even if
they are chance to survive would be
unintelligible and untranslatable
it was possible to translate any passage
of old speak into newspeak
unless it unless it either referred to
some technical process
or some very simple no very simple
everyday action
or was already orthodox good thinkful
would be the new speaking expression and
tendency
in practice this meant no book written
before approximately 1960 could be
translated as a whole
pre-revolutionary literature could only
be subjected to
ideological translation that is
alteration in sense as well as language
take for example the well-known passage
from the declaration of independence we
hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal that they are endowed by
their creator
with certain inalienable rights that
among these are life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their powers
from the consent of the governed that
whatever
any form of government becomes
destructive of those ends it is the
right of the people
to alter or abolish it and so
to institute new government
it would have been quite impossible to
render this
into newspeak while keeping it to the
sense of the original
the nearest one could come to doing so
would be to
swallow the whole passage up in the
single word
crime thing
the whole thing was just crime speak
goes on here a good deal of the
literature the past was indeed already
being transformed this way
considerations of prestige made it
desirable to preserve
the memory of certain historical figures
while at the same time bridging their
achievements
into line with the phyllis with the
philosophy of ingsoc
various writers such as shakespeare
milton swift byron dickens and some of
the
others were therefore in the process of
translation
when the task had been completed their
original writings with all
else that survived of the literature of
the past would be destroyed
these translations were a slow difficult
business
and it was not expected that they would
be finished before the first or second
date
decade of the 21st century there were
also
large quantities of merely utilitarian
literature
indispensable technical manuals and the
like that had to be treated the same way
it was chiefly in order to allow time
for the preliminary work
of translation that the final adoption
of newspeak
had been fixed for so late
a date as 2050.
so there you go that's this and this
that's this appendix and
and you know you can see that they
failed they failed to
change the language which means they
failed to get control of speech they
failed to
to ban free thought because of that
and because of that they failed to
successfully
enslave the world in
their tyranny so
very
very scary
very scary document
and that's the language that's the
control of the language
based on reality based on history
language control of of of the government
of a dystopian future and
and you can see it's amazing how close
orwell got it
and as cowboy warned us it's something
we need to watch out for
and
we can't control everything but
we need to control we can and and going
back to the
the beginning of this that's why
we don't have sponsors here who might
limit what we say
or limit what we talk to or limit who we
talk to
that's why this podcast right here what
we're doing
that's why it's open and it's free for
everyone
so that as many people as possible here
the lessons of history
hear the
reflections of human nature in the past
so we can all
learn and we can remember what's
happened in the past so we don't repeat
it
so we've managed to make maintain
control of that
but we don't really have control of
everything here and and one of the
things that we don't have control of is
the platforms that we come out on
and we rely obviously we rely heavily on
the platforms and the platforms
have been good to good good to us
for the most part so far all the
platforms wherever you're listening this
right now
we've been treated well it's been good
but at the same time any of those
platforms
that we publish this podcast on could
they could actually shut us down if they
wanted to
they could pull the plug they could hold
us hostage
and i don't like that and and we don't
like that
so we did some contingency planning
little contingency planning look hope
what's what's the purpose of contingency
hopefully you don't need to use a
contingency plan that's the hope
is that you don't need to use a
contingency plan but
if we have to we we we figured we better
do some contingency planning
just in case so we're gonna we're
putting together our own platform as a
contingency
setting up our own network or
i guess reinforcing it being prepared
if we have to i hope it doesn't go that
way but we'll be ready to
we'll have a little sovereign land of
our own
echo charles our own little sovereign
little
area little digital land little little
autonomous place
that we we will have control over
that we can do what we want
and echo's been working hard on this
right
um to put this together
a place where we can muster if we have
to a place where we can bring our
friends
their podcast if we need to a place
where we can talk and we can argue and
we can
theorize a place where we can dissent
we can subvert and we can rebel a place
where we're free
a place where we are free to do what we
want to do
in case we need it
just okay so sounds fired up to me
actually
what does it mean pragmatically so like
i said echo has been
for the past few weeks putting together
some
the the the actual sovereign world
the the underground the the death core
underground
doing the technical work besides just
pressing record
echo has skills a separate so so
so what we set up what echoes set up
because pretty much
i didn't do anything besides like say we
better do this just in case
and echo said roger that so a separate
an underground a podcast feed that's
underground right um
a separate underground forum
a separate underground kind of way to
communicate
to us and listen
this podcast that we're doing right here
the jocko podcast this will remain
free and available to all
for as long as it is allowed to be free
and available i will never
change that by my own volition and
believe me
we have had opportunity upon opportunity
to
do that to go behind the fire wall
okay well the pay wall
and we haven't done that and we won't do
that
so as long as this as long as we're
allowed to do this we'll do it
but if but we do need to have
contingency planning if you want to get
in the game if you want to support the
underground
that would be appreciated and
and in order to like when we do that in
order we're going to give something
in order to kind of show our
appreciation we'll do some things on the
underground
to you know
show our appreciation you know maybe
some additional sort of podcast
things maybe some podcasts that don't
fit in the typical format of a usual
jocko podcast because that's one thing
that
you know i think of that the i try and
might maintain
a consistency with the jocko podcast
that when you
press play you kind of know what you're
getting or you at least have some idea
so for me to throw out something that's
you know really uh
maybe a lot shorter or maybe it's
different subject matter or maybe it's
some kind of current events based thing
whatever i don't know but
we'll be able to do that we'll be able
to do that we'll be able to do whatever
we want because we will have pure
pure freedom we'll answer questions
probably do some q a a little bit more
because you know
at some point if you recall the early
days the podcast it was like hey i could
just respond to you on twitter which i
would because it was just hey
oh you asked a question cool i'll just
answer you oh and if it was a good
question maybe bring it on the podcast
and answer it
but that became overwhelming um because
there's just too many questions
to answer them all i haven't even done a
q a in a while
so we'll do some q a type stuff
this is you know so you can ask
questions direct
um now you were saying something about
like doing some kind of live
connections yeah
if we choose to yeah so if people want
it well it's we
me the proverbial all of us if we if
that's our choice yes uh yeah so that's
what we're doing
obviously we'll be open to whatever
suggestions you you know you got
so that's what we're doing
well we got gotta pay for it there's
gonna be a little price a little price
to pay for freedom
we came up with a a pricing number
if you can figure out the layers of this
number
what will they win let's let's this
needs to be rewarded
if you can i i bet someone can figure it
out that's possible
the if you if you're if you want to join
eight dollars and 18 cents a month
and if you can figure out the layers
between behind 8 18
let us know you will win something
something yeah it'll be cool or
something it'll be a cool something
do you think it's so obvious that
everyone will figure it out
it's very possible okay so maybe you me
if depending on how many people get oh
let's say this the first three people
okay that get it will be rewarded
but that way you know look a little bit
of a little bit of cost for freedom that
way we can
invest in all these different things we
want to do and and by the way
if you're freaked out or you're like
money grab and whatever
cool no no factor if you can't afford
that if it's too much we want you to
listen
echo will take care of you he's writing
down that email right now because he
just made it up but he will have it live
and yeah but if you can't afford a chip
in that's awesome too and we appreciate
it
there's also you know talking to some
other friends right now that have other
podcasts about
you know giving them the same kind of
bringing them into the fold
and that's where we're at and like i
said i hope it doesn't come to a point
where you need to go full
deaf core underground
but we prepare we make contingency plans
and we execute
so we'll do some cool stuff and we'll be
ready
one more excerpt from 1984. here's the
quote
don't you see that the whole aim of
newspeak is to narrow the range of
thought in the end we shall make
[ __ ] crime literally impossible
because there will be no words in which
to express it
end quote
well we will maintain the words
and we will maintain our
freedom
echo yes sir so how do people
join the jocko deathcore underground
go to jockounderground.com
that's it straight up that's all you
gotta do go there and that's where you
can join if you want
there you go cool kind of crazy what
so obviously we're we're not just
sitting around
waiting for a dystopian future to
to be delivered unto us no we are not no
we're preparing for it yes sir we also
got to prepare for other things in life
yeah we want to be prepared we want to
have capabilities
yes what do you recommend so okay
so bad and i didn't i vaguely
heard of this book 1988 seriously yeah
crazy enough i don't know maybe i
i don't know like maybe i'm quiet that's
just not how okay
i don't know maybe i missed it i don't
know okay
but it's really interesting because like
there are little
parts of that like we all of that stuff
that they're doing and trying to do or
whatever we do that
in little ways and it's actually the
thing is it's useful and it's actually
beneficial in a lot of ways
as long as it's not across the board
what do you think we're doing
you lost me there you want to make
things binary which we talked about
on the last episode actually that's
completely different
it's the same concept except it's used
for good
so like dude you're getting wrapped
around the fact that you have a computer
programming mind and you want to take
the english language and put it into
a totally formatted system it
doesn't again work again if it's across
the board you know why it doesn't work
i'll tell you why it doesn't work it's
like jujitsu
language is like the english language is
like jujitsu words come into it
and they get adapted into it if they're
good if they work if they don't then
they get shut down
oh yeah fully and then the same thing
with like methodology in general so if
you
like okay so the binary thing right by
anything they're they're implementing
that in language across the
or that concept anyway across the board
that's bad
but you can use that in specific nuanced
ways
to make it like a more efficient
situation like working out or something
like that
where okay so i was working out today
actually
something tells me you just want to tell
me this story and you're given some kind
of
no no so this is this is an exact
this is why this whole book is
interesting it's it basically one of the
many lessons or whatever
it's like you can take a a good thing
and just take it too far
if you implement it across the board
dichotomy of leadership a lot of this
stuff
yeah fully a lot of stuff again in teeny
tiny doses or used just like sparingly
is like it's good things like
salt really put a little bit of salt on
sauce it's pretty nice
okay put too much salt or you put all
salt right you're dead true
so anyway i'm working out and
my little son he's like four now he's
doing you know he's
he's copying more and trying to
understand and and actively
understanding like work these kettlebell
swings
yeah he's doing little kids like the
kettlebell swings don't they
just you know i i don't want them to
quite do
my daughter does him or wants to do him
whatever i don't i don't know i don't
need her
like sleeping and bashing her shin with
that little kettlebell i don't know
anyway burpees all day yeah we can talk
about that offline
yes sir having your kids do kettlebell
swings is a good thing it seems like
beneficial yeah
okay cool um work on that coordination
if we're worried about
leg hits shin hits yes sir okay make
some shoes
make sense to me sorry anyway
um so my daughter was there and she was
like
um talking about like how her like
because she went to that running thing
where her legs are all sore and all this
stuff meanwhile my son he's over getting
after it or whatever
right and he's like hey i'm doing this
or whatever so i can be strong
so my daughters are listening so it's
like yeah it's true
and you're gonna understand in life
answer me this
what's better to be strong or weak
strong they say strong
what's it better to know how to do
something or to not know how to do
something
say to know how to do something so okay
what's better to be healthy or unhealthy
they say healthy or whatever right
so obviously life is there's way more to
it than what you ought to do kettlebell
swings or not your kettlebells
that see that's another one of those
things on the surface you'd say yeah
kettlebell swings all day
but the point is there's a lot more to
it than that
but if i use that binary terminology
just for that moment it's going to
send a message more effectively
granted it's a good message at this
point but you apply that across the
board right you just
eliminate understanding nuance all these
important things
i get it i get it your your theory is
accepted
but it's really really
you're taking like something massively
destructive and and just taking a little
tiny piece of it
and saying it's good yeah like salt okay
like i said we'll go with it but if if i
have a steak come on choco steak right
all day whatever steak i put a little
bit of salt on it
does that make it better or worse in
your opinion that's an opinion can we
put pepper on it too yes sir yes
okay what if you put the whole thing
through
all salt the whole thing will be good
actually let me start eliminating some
of the steaks to make
room for more of the salt in fact at the
end of the day let's remove the whole
steak just salt and pepper oh wait you
want it and pepper right some salt and
pepper
right you're dead it's not even good
it's not even the same thing you see
insane
yeah i got it so a little bit is good
a lot of it so a little bit of language
control inside your own family with your
children
trying to explain to them basic things
like a binary decision-making process
between good and bad in an immediate way
right is is a positive thing
to influence their thoughts for sure got
it no
across the board maybe not just remind
me not to let you become dictator where
you've run that
game on the whole country well there you
go
share the world too all right anyway
speaking of working out yeah i worked
out today
we're expanding our capabilities our
strength
our health all that stuff right that's
what this path is
so in the spirit of being pathful
you see what i'm doing there anyway we
got supplements boom jackal fuel we got
stuff for your joints so you don't have
to think about them aching
anymore you have to worry about thinking
about them
aching anymore thinking about that stuff
won't even exist it'll be
impossible to even think about it those
thought crimes
etc anyway joint warfare um
also super krill oil these things help
your joints boom keep you in the game
even as we age through this human
existence also discipline and discipline
go
it's for your mind everybody too it's a
daily thing i think
but yes enhance your cognitive
capabilities as far as capabilities go
have you improved your routine where
you're 100 on krill
and and and joint warfare with no no
holes in your game no lapses
um did you just use the word hundred
percent
yeah no okay how can you not do that why
don't you just put them when you brush
your teeth you take it i know
uh well i thought we covered that before
as far as the brushing the teeth part
because the routine is it's nuanced
anyway
it's because uh
to really point it out it's
when the whole covid thing came to my
shores i was like
i grabbed the vitamin d3 in the cold war
i was
that like my mind shifted to that as the
priority
and then it'd be like one day oh i
didn't take the krill oil
you know not because like oh i neglected
i was like okay i'm just gonna take this
now
or whatever it's not as implemented into
the
routine as it should be it's really
crazy to me
yeah really crazy to me that this is not
a big
like thing dude there's a little thing
you could just do well
with the bottles next to your toothbrush
you know what it is it no
this is this is really what it is now
that i'm like analyzing my whole mind
because you're right
you're you're like we know it like helps
you so much
yeah yeah yes so here's the thing i'm
violating two rules or maybe it's just
one rule with different terms
resting on my laurels and complacency
okay
so you know how like bro my joints don't
hurt so i'm not compelled
to solve any problem you see what i'm
saying but i'm not kind of i'm not
taking my own advice you know how you
like you don't want to think about two
days go by and then you do
feel your joints uh it's like like four
five
six days you know you go six days
until i start feeling it yeah but oh i'm
not like off them i don't have issues
right now
but i'm just saying like as far as 100
daily the way
that that when i when i do put it
together i'm just not doing that
but i'm getting there but yeah no issues
for sure but that's i think
baby steps bro we're getting there we're
working on it we're working on that
discipline
yeah so the lesson there is
even take i got to take my own advice
we don't want to think about that kind
of stuff but the only way to not think
about your joints hurting or
hurting in the future is to through
discipline
take them every day see now you're like
that guy that's
you know giving advice about something
they're not actually doing
yeah it's kind of sad
i'll give the advice hey take them every
day there you go i do
okay don't do what echo does do do what
i do well technically every day i don't
know that i say take it every
day i say take it and so you don't have
to worry about your joints but look i'm
saying right now and i'm start doing it
right now how about that
next time you check in with me 100 i'm
worried to check in with you
anyway you might be on cocaine or
something anyway
discipline and discipline go for your
brain for your body for your whole thing
real life really this wouldn't go in a
can
that's what we talk about you like
energy drinks cool you don't like energy
drinks
yeah i know why cool does splint go in a
can
is everything that an energy drink
should be and more
in my opinion it's like a healthy need
yourself to do a corner right there you
know
he wanted to give the counter example
when you've painted yourself into a
corner you couldn't escape
i'm a creator it's all the good without
the bad it's it's all the good without
the background that's all the good
without the
end of the good oh with the bed yep go
get some
yeah it's fully good cinwawa right now
it's online you can get it wherever you
want accessibility is not the issue
here yeah yeah it's about making the
correct choice
by the way freedom to choose
freedom to choose right thank you yeah
you can get this stuff at wawa you can
get a vitamin shop you can get it at
origin maine.com you can actually get it
on amazon
all this stuff molk protein
discipline just the whole nine yards
check it out if you want to
if you want to get after it also at
origin main
you got jiu-jitsu gear because we are
training jiu-jitsu
for a multitude of reasons as we found
out on that last podcast
is it better to be capable or incapable
we want to be capable if you choose to
fight someone
do you want the choice to fight someone
and win or no
better to be capable or uncapable yeah
so is it better to do jiu-jitsu or on
jiu-jitsu and they want to do jiu-jitsu
jiu-jitsu is double plus good yes
yes sir so go to go to origin main.com
get geez get rash cards you can also get
jeans boots
t-shirts and the thing is all the stuff
is made in america
all made in a factory up in maine
and it's awesome we're bringing
manufacturing back to america so
support if you can
what else chocolate store it's called
jocko store
same deal if you want to represent uh on
this path
if you want to be pathful and
represented at the same time
just hey man you can go jocklestore.com
get a disciplined shirt hoodie hat
some rash guards on there we do have a
t-shirt club if you're into it and if
you're into
representing monthly variety different
stuff
so that's this is the kind of thing
where maybe that's where the ungood
t-shirt comes from right
oh like slides in as far as improvement
let's face it
it's very cool if you kind of if you're
kind of in the game right
no big deal yes like if i see something
with an ungood t-shirt on from
from that it'll be like yup so you might
want to put that one in the lineup
put it in the lineup
idea good one i like it it's uh it's not
on good i'll tell you that
um but yes t-shirt kyle every month you
know it's like one of those things in
the theme of today's deal
it's it's not narrowing down your
options
for representation it's expanding them
see i'm saying so anyway yeah t-shirt
club uh check that out if you want boom
on jackostore.com
also uh subscribe to the podcast we
gotta you know
the platforms that we're on like i said
they've been good to us
let's hope they stay that way subscribe
to it check it out we also got
we got this podcast we got the jocko
unraveling podcast we got grounded
podcast we got the warrior kid podcast
we got a youtube channel where echo does
excessive amounts of cgi
and uncanny fakes or what what do you
say uncanny valley
uncanny he's he's out there in the
uncanny valley he's walking through the
uncali vanier
uncanny valley of death and he fears no
robots so check out that
also got little excerpts on there we got
psychological warfare
which is a me talking for like
a minute two minutes three minutes at a
time out of whack
and i'm telling you put your donut down
i'm telling you get out of bed
telling you why to do it i'm gonna help
you
achieve what you want to achieve
what you don't feel like yeah even when
you don't feel like it flip side canvas
stuff you can hang on your wall some
people would say
art yeah i would say graphic
visual representations of the path of
justice
got a bunch of books a bunch of books
about face leadership strategy and
tactics discipline equals freedom field
manual brand new version
you can probably can probably get that
one for you know
somebody that you know that could use a
little
a little adjustment in life maybe it's
the kind of person
maybe it's the kind of person that right
now they could use some help maybe
when they wake up in the morning instead
of having a routine
where they take the supplements they're
supposed to take maybe
they could just figure out through this
book they could
find the discipline that it takes to put
a bottle next to their toothbrush and
take it
thank you taco for that anyways
you can check out that book this week
with freedom field manual way the
warrior kid four field manuals out
way the warrior kid one two and three
mike and the dragons extreme ownership
dichotomy leadership
we've got a salon front which is
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership
go to echelonfront.com for details on
that we got ef
online we're on there all the time live
doing q and a's we got discussions
happening
with an entire network of leaders from
all kinds of different industries
and the echelon front team myself the
rest of team we're on there
all the time so check out efonline.com
we have the muster
which is our leadership seminar
we got phoenix march 3rd and 4th orlando
may 25th and 26th
in las vegas october 28th and 29th go to
extremeownership.com
look by that time let's face it cove
it's going to be over
we got the vaccine we got vitamin d we
got all kinds of good stuff going on
i'm calling it well let's hope it's over
let's hope it's over
then look we didn't have any mustards
this year so
obviously we got a bunch of people that
are already signed up to go but if you
want to
if you want to come check it out at
streamownership.com we got ef overwatch
we got
executive leadership for your company if
you want
to hire a former military
person that understands the principles
we talk about all the time
check out ef overwatch.com and if you
want to help
service members active duty service
members retired service members their
families
gold star families then check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or get involved check out
america's mightywarriors.org
and if you want to bring some dystopian
future into your present day
we got you covered you can get more of
my despondent diatribes or
you can get more of ekko's disoriented
differentiation
you can find us on the interwebs and we
definitely got some disoriented
differentiations from you today didn't
we
and you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on instagram which you know
echo only refers to as
the gram and on that facebook
echo is adequate charles i am at
jacqueline and thanks to all the
military
people out there in the world that fight
against tyranny and oppression
every single day and keep us free and
thanks to police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
all first responders for being there
when we
are in our time of need and to everyone
else out there
don't take freedom for granted
and countless sacrifices
have been made to secure freedom and to
preserve it and if
we have to preserve it and i know that
we don't do it perfectly
but i do believe that in the battle of
good versus evil and light versus dark
and truth versus lie
i believe that truth and light and good
will prevail but there may be times of
darkness and for those times we will be
ready
and we we may have to go underground at
some point
but we will never surrender and we will
never submit to tyranny
discipline equals freedom and freedom
will
overcome all and until next time this is
echo
and jocko out